longer the what were the hotel
accommodations for the Raiders on the
road do you remember any places that
were just not good situations golly I
remember I you know it's interesting
because Diane was up in Buffalo this
weekend uh for the Patriots game and I
remember back then you know the back in
1992 the accommodations particularly
when it was cold the wind would
literally blow right through the at the
doors in the hotel room and they and
they gleefully would call you for your
six a.m. wake-up call good morning at
6am this is your wake-up call forecast
for 25 below with the windchill today
that was the call you got in Buffalo
Green Bay was like that too worst
conditions you ever played in green bay
and Buffalo my final year the green bay
game was the game where the Lambeau leap
took it's uh took its first light no
really ought to go is Leroy Butler yes
and really close like it was much like
the NFC Championship game that we
covered up there when the Giants upset
the Packers on their way to you know
what many consider to be is as big a
Super Bowl upset along with the Patriots
versus the rams and colts and all that
did you go sleeveless when it was really
cold uh no i don't think so not when it
was that kind of cold uh that's a kind
of cold where if you lead your dog or
your child out for a half hour they lock
you up they lock you up then but you
didn't do that you didn't do that no no
I wore my last year you know if I knew
then what I know now kind of thing I
wore scuba gloves and I wore a spring
suit for anyone who in your group there
that
serves her body serves it's the one that
goes down just to your biceps and mid
thigh and that worked great now the only
thing is your face in your feet done by
the time you get on the plane plus i ah
I had a fractured hand in five places
and the flight home was let's play the
game of how can we kill the pain so you
had a couple of drinks a couple of
everything down yeah did any of your
knives it didn't work did any of you
guys ever drink before games not that I
know of not that I know of when it's
cold out like that the last thing you're
worried about is who's drinking it's you
know you could stand outside the locker
room and you know kind of go well he's
gonna play he's and play nope he's not
going away you know that that bench you
know as as kind of the early versions of
the warm bench were not great yeah it
was either or you either didn't get any
heat or your feet were on fire so it was
a little bit of both but what an
interesting weekend huh I know it's been
great we're by the way talking to how
along the Hall of Famer NFL on Fox
analyst does cam newton have a point
here howling of is he officiated looked
at differently you know I think in some
cases he is when he's in the pocket I I
think there are some cases where he does
and it's I think it's the Shaquille
O'Neal effect and they've used that
analogy before down there in Carolina
you know and and you've been around cam
right yes you've walked up on cam you
walk up on cam it's almost like you have
tourettes it's like damn yeah you're a
big sorry he is just enormous and and I
think you know whether I don't think
it's consciously i think it's it's
something that the officials are doing
you know without thinking about it it's
well he's big he can take that kind of
hit whereas if it's brady if it's breeze
if it's you know fill in the blank
quarterback now
yesterday there were probably two hits
that should have been flagged you know
the collides Campbell hit low probably
should have been hit and the play read
he kind of flushes out to his left and
gets hit and it seemed like it took
forever for the guy to slam him on the
ground that to me was was a little bit
much now when camp pulls the ball down
all bets are off and cameras said that's
part of my game and that is part of his
game but i've said this i think putting
on a russell wilson demo tape and you
know they've got the Manning camp I'm
going to open up a camp for quarterback
sliding I'll make millions because half
of them can't and it's so much more
difficult for someone who's 65 66 to get
down quickly vs. Russell whose 511 to
get down quickly Russell gets down
quicker takes your heads and cam how
many times you've seen cam finish a
drive headfirst finish your run
headfirst that's on camp and and it's
again it's just a matter of time you
know you're around Rodney you know you
you're around players you're out coaches
they will get you yes they will get you
it's just a matter of time if I hit you
with a hammer enough you will blink it's
just a question of time that's all how
did Alex Smith get cleared to go back in
after the first hit when he banged his
head on the turf and he's he's stumbling
like Mike Tyson looking for his
mouthpiece against Buster Douglas yeah
and now i think you know obviously for a
number of reasons for you know the
league has I think genuine concern about
head trauma and there's also existing or
any future litigation so you know I I
think they'll be an adjustment made
because of that although i think it's an
anomaly i'm not sure who is clearing him
was it mek they said independent
yeah was it mek that he just taught me
mech I don't know but he came back they
at least wait until after a half time to
bring him back to make you know give the
perception that he's gone through
concussion protocol but well the yeah
and the visual optics are not great know
and somebody we've all seen it were a
player and I've been there you know I
mean I I got hit one time the end of the
Santa you again I think I hit chuck
muncie on the goal line and for those
who don't remember chuck muncie he was
big man I woke up in my locker I don't
remember I can I lost it and I call it
losing time it's one thing where you
know you get the cartoon thing were you
know the sparkles and you know and all
birds are birds are chirping and it's
true it's whoever did that the cartoon
had been knocked out because they got it
right but there's another part of it is
who are you and what am I on the third
down package am I on the punk coverage
team and the other one is which is scary
is where you lose time uh you know I
remember waking up in the San Diego
locker room down there and I'm like how
to get in here I didn't go down I you
know I don't think I went I do I didn't
go down because no one helped me I'll
feel I just followed the group I was
like a lemming going off the side of a
cliff if i gave you a do over would you
have retired earlier no i think i think
where i was at that point you know when
i when i retired near 3333 30-34 january
six of my final year so i played in the
pro bowl at 34 that year and i thought
you know what I'm held together with
duct tape and glue I've been you know
shot up maybe eight games that year
seven I just for me to be able to do
what I did at the level that I wanted to
do it at I it just it was too much and
Chris was eight years old
how was five or four and how he was
three and you know I mean I didn't know
which day at school was burger day you
know I I was so obsessed with what I was
doing it was time and I'm glad I made
that decision when I did because it gave
me the opportunity to coach Little
League baseball for eight years high
school football for eight years and be a
part of that and watch them grow and
enjoy them so it was the right time for
me what's good to catch up with you as
always and have fun this weekend with
the Raiders and Broncos and hopefully
we'll we'll catch up with you soon how
about how about the Raiders I'm all in
on him twenty-three thousand euros on
the road what damn the torpedoes they're
back Hallie 23 penalties by a jacked a
long time coming but it's fun thanks bud
talk to you soon that's a hella long NFL
on Fox the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience